here's a proof by mathematical induction
and it's an inequality and it's
basically a mathematicians nightmare
prove that to the power of two n
multiply by n factorial all squared is
greater than n equal to 2 N or factorial
now this is a mathematician that way
because it's got every nasty ingrian
possible really
you've got the end up in the index
that's gross
you got a factorial you've got that
raised to a power you got all these
terrible ingredients that make this a
really really sort of awkward proof to
do but we can't do it if you stick with
it and you're patient by mathematical
induction where do we start
well you've got to go with the first
allowable value okay so I think I got
asked to prove this for positive
integers and the first positive integer
is 1 okay so let's give that a go left
hand side in this case even just
evaluating it is pretty gross so you've
got 2 to the power of 2 times 1 which is
just 2 then you've got 1 factorial
squared ok so what do we got here well
that's for 2 squares for 1 factorial is
just 1 and so 1 squared is also 1 so
it's just 4 that's that's done okay what
about the right hand side well that's 2
times 1 factorial that's 2 times 1 by
definition which is 2 so in this case
the left hand side is greater than or
equal to the right hand side which is
great so therefore it's true for our
first allowable value which is always a
good sign okay right next step in a
mathematical induction proof is I'm
gonna assume that the statement is true
for some arbitrary value K and K has to
follow the same rules that n follows so
it's a positive integer as well so what
does the statement look like I'm just
gonna replace all my ends with K's
so you end up with this
and there's my assumption okay now the
third step the real important step of
the mathematical induction proof which
is I now want to on the basis of that
assumption assumption prove that this
statement is true for the next value
along k plus 1 alright so what does that
look like well what am I going to get
here when I replace all the case with k
plus 1 I'm gonna have 2 to the power of
2 k plus 2 that's this term here then
I've got K factorial will now become K
plus 1 factorial right so that's K plus
1 factorial and that's squared I want to
show you that's greater than or equal to
now when I when I put the K plus 1 in
there it's gonna become 2 k plus 2
factorial this is what I want to try and
prove which looks pretty awful okay so
how do I go about this now you can see I
mean many many inequality proofs you'll
start with your assumption you'll say by
assumption this and then you'll twist
and turn this to try and get it into
this form but you may have seen if you
had a look at some of our other videos
that another common strategy is to take
this manipulate it a little bit so
you've got a statement that you can
actually know to be true now you can't
actually write this because that's what
that's what my final line should be but
I can say consider so what I'm gonna
think about is what would happen if I
move this part over here over to the
left hand side okay so what it would
look like is you know 2 k plus 2 times k
plus 1 factorial squared minus this
extra part okay now if I can prove that
this black line if I can prove that
that's true then that means that I've
proved this is true and this is
something that's a little easier to work
with it's proving that something is
positive we can use all sorts of
algebraic tricks to help us there ok so
what we'll do is we'll consider just the
left hand side let's look at that 2 to
the K sorry is that - that's it that's
meant to be a 2 there isn't it
to the 2k plus 2 multiplied by K plus 1
factorial or squared minus 2k plus 2
factorial
okay so I'm gonna think about this line
now the first thing I want to do is it's
it's very complicated at the moment
there are some things that I can expand
and I want to expand it in such a way
don't expand this line in such a way
that I can use my assumption okay so
watch watch what'll happen I'm looking
for this this part here
okay the to the 2k and the K factorial
or squared because I know I can see it's
somewhere in here if I can expand it
right so let's do that these two to the
2k plus 2 is really 2 squared so this is
equal to 2 squared x to the 2k yeah
that's just by index laws ok and what do
I have in here well this is if I break
this apart k plus 1 factorial is really
k plus 1 times k factorial ok so no big
dramatic changes from there to there
I've just taken the largest term out and
that thing's all squared and I'll leave
this guy over here for a moment will
mess with him in a second ok all right
now what was the point in me number 1
breaking apart the index here and number
2 breaking apart this factorial well I'm
trying to get at this there's that to
the 2k there see it there and came
factored all squared it's right there
okay so I just need to break this apart
a little more if I've got this 2 squared
becomes a 4 and that to the 2k I'll
leave that there now here this is the
square of a product okay that's a
product in there and that's the square
so the square root product is the
product of the squares so I've got a K
plus 1 squared and then I've got K
factorial squared that's that's I've got
that that those two terms out of this
term minus 2k plus 2 factorial ok so I'm
almost ready now let's have a think
about this remember what I'm after is is
this component here ok so just to make
it really really
let me write these two parts in this
line together okay
so what I've got is no four at the front
I've got a K plus 1 all squared there
and then I've got multiply it by 2 to
the 2k K factorial or swear okay and
there's this piece here okay now you all
watch this this is the tricky part
in terms of logic this is what's
confusing okay have a look at that piece
there right now on the basis of my
assumption I I can know something about
this piece namely that that piece there
is bigger than 2 K factorial okay so I
know that this piece is there already
if I swap it out for this piece okay so
I say what happens if I leave everything
else the same but I swap out that piece
for a 2 K factorial okay now everything
else in the line is the same okay so
what's the relationship between these
two well we said we assumed this is
bigger than that okay namely that this
is bigger than this okay
so therefore since that's the only thing
I've changed from this line to this line
right and this is bigger than that then
I should know this entire line should be
bigger than this entire line right so
therefore this equal sign is no longer
an equal sign it's an inequality okay
this entire line because of this swap is
greater than or equal to this line by
assumption so this is the part that's
actually mathematical induction I've
used the assumption now and now I want
to see if I can prove that there's
something to do with this okay
namely that it's greater than or equal
to zero okay so watch this how can I do
this how can I prove that this is all
greater than zero that it's positive
well I can see that this factorial here
and this factorial here I can I can do
some factorizing here right because this
two K factorial is hidden inside here
okay so let's let's notice that for
starters I'll just expand that
it's gonna be K squared Q K plus 1 then
I've got my 2 K factorial here now 2 k
plus 2 or factorial right what it really
is equal to is 2 k plus 2 2 k plus 1 and
then all the other ones which is 2 K
factorial yeah you see how all I have to
do to turn a 2 K factorial into K P
factorial multiplied the next two terms
are long ok so now that I've broken that
apart I can factorize out 2 K factorial
I see I see them both there ok so let's
take that 2 K factorial at the front ok
now what's left well I've got 4 lots of
this that's going to be 4 K squared plus
8 K plus 4 and then I'm going to
subtract now what happens when this is
what's left after I factorize right what
happens when I expand those well I'm
gonna get a 4k squared plus 2k plus 4 K
plus 2 that's just the expansion to K
all factorials at the front ok now you
can see some cancel he's gonna have in
here right this 4 K squared in this 4 K
squared okay that's all I've got 8 K
here and I've got 6 K here so when I
subtract them I'll be left with UK and
I've got a 4 and I subtract a 2 so at
least Mewtwo okay so what have I
established well I've got this result
right at the end and I know that what I
started with is bigger than this but all
of this right all of this must be
greater than 0 since you know this guy
it's it's it's going to be positive
right actually is not even included in
the boundary because K is going to be
positive and also 2k plus 2 that's also
positive so if you're multiplying
together two positive numbers then the
product will also important if so that's
why I can say the whole thing is
positive okay all right now therefore
whatever I started with whatever I
started with okay is greater than zero
now what did I start with I started with
this okay so now I'm going to take that
original line
and I can say therefore to to the 2 K +
2 x k plus 1 factorial or squared minus
2 k plus 2 factorial all of that is
greater than or equal to 0
that's what I just established okay so
now I can kick that that term there over
the other side 2k plus 2 factorial and
what is this what is this well what's
the significance of it if you go all the
way back that's what I was trying to
prove namely that the statement is true
for N equals K plus 1 if I use my
assumption okay so I've established that
therefore it's true the statement is
true for N equals K plus 1 given that
it's true for N equals K which is our
assumption okay and that's that's it
really now that I've proved it true for
K plus y if it's true for K and since
it's true for one the first allowable
value that it means it's gonna be true
for all of them which is the principle
of mathematical induction the statement
is true for all the values that we were
stating before which is the positive
integers